Welcome to my small dojo. This is um an
introductory film because uh I've been
looking at people from around the world
and what they do is those who wish to
take the
Bukiwaza certification levels. Uh they
send me in a film or films of the stages
they
do. This is the certificate. Uh this is
a copy actually but this is the copy of
the certificate that uh each person gets
once they've achieved
their their level.
There's around nine or 10 of us in the
world who were awarded the five uh
certifications by
cytoensing and I think there might be
other teachers who give out certificates
but I I think I'm the only person who
will offer the whole five whereby the
recipient finally gets chance to when
I'm no longer on Earth, they can they
can then start awarding this spooky
certification
uh in hopes that we will keep sight of
senses and no senses weapons as taught
in alive clear and precise in the way we
were taught it.
So, uh, the way I do it
is the you would send me, let's say you
would be taking the the second level
because I'm going to show you some
common points that come up on uh the
second level. And the same things with
the first level, but the first level's
uh Ken
Saburi, the second level's the Joe. So
I'm just going
to specify on
that what weak points keep coming up.
Now I have on the third level on on one
particular student spent 17 hours now
looking at their their weak points and
sending them screenshots of the showing
the weak points and asking them to
correct them and then to resend the film
in.
So to save me keep looking at them, this
is what I
suggest. If you want to take part in the
Bukiwaza certification, you send the
form to me and then when you send me the
first film,
uh you you make it the film, you put it
on YouTube or some device where you can
send me the link so I can view it, but
you review it yourself. Now, if it was
YouTube, I go into settings and I set it
for
25. It's the slowest of the slow. You
can go slower than that, but I look at
it frame by frame so that I can stop it
at the point that I see it where there's
an error.
So, I urge you to do the same because
there's a lot of points that you will
perhaps see, save you sending me in a
film just for me to correct what you'll
be able to see
yourself. At the point of sending me the
form and the first film, you then
deposit the money uh the fee. I don't
want the money and the form before that.
I I only and and the hours I spend the
minimum I seem to have narrowed it down
to is between five and 7 hours for the
first and second
scroll. I say scroll, but uh it's the
certificate I showed
you. My hope is to get people somewhere
in the world to get to all five levels.
When you get to the fourth level, you
would have covered everything. But to
get to the fifth level, I will be asking
you to show me a series of films or one
film of going back to the beginning and
showing me from the first level all the
way to the fourth
level. We'll correct anything that's
um worked its way in where there's weak
points. Come back. And once I'm happy
that that uh you've completed it, you
will get the authorization to then award
charge and certify people yourself. I
will give you all the information that
you need, the stamps that you will
required to do this. No one is near
there at the moment, but we have been
only going a couple of years now. at
this at this stage. But if you're of a
high rank, you may be able to
um not go to the standard times and do
one after the other. So you soon as
you've completed one and I'm happy, then
you can start straight away practicing
or even take the second one. Uh it
depends again on your Dan level. The
higher the down grade, the more I would
have thought you could have uh gone
through them quickly. But you will also
have errors because I haven't seen
anybody yet who hasn't got errors. I'm
sure if I do mine again, I've got
errors. We're only human beings. Saitto
Sensei said he saw Osansi make many
mistakes. So cuz
but I
think I gave my word to Saitto Sensei
that I would continue his Bukiwaza and
and keep them. He said please cherish
them and keep them going uh and pure and
this is what I'm trying to do and I'm
grateful for you who take it want wish
to take it on. Now a lot of people
um this is rather rude of me but a lot
of people are very arrogant and they
write to me saying oh we know it and and
um is it worth them taking it because
they already know it so well. Well you
think you may know it but these are
teaching level certificates. I'm not
just looking for somebody who can do the
carter and it looks reasonably good. I
want to know, can you teach it frame by
frame, stage by stage? Do you know all
the points about where your hands, feet,
and where they should be? And this is
what I'd like to go on to
now
and and break it down piece by
piece. Thank you.